-Performing his hit "Last Last"
from his album
"Love, Damini,"
once again, Burna Boy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ E don cast, last last ♪
♪ Na everybody go
chop breakfast ♪
-♪ Shayo ♪
♪ Na ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Shayo ♪
♪ Igbo ♪
♪♪
♪ You go bow for the result o ♪
♪ Nothing to discuss o,
cause I dey win by default ♪
♪ And without any doubt o ♪
♪ Omo me I be adult o ♪
♪ I no go fit take your ♪
-♪ I no go fit
take your insult o ♪
-♪ Omo mind as you dey talk o ♪
♪ I put my life into my job ♪
♪ And I know I'm in trouble ♪
♪ She manipulate my love o ♪
♪ I no holy and I no denge pose
like Baba Fryo ♪
♪ My eye o don cry o ♪
♪ I need igbo and shayo ♪
♪ I need...♪
-♪ Igbo and shayo ♪
-♪ Shayo ♪
-♪ I need igbo and shayo ♪
♪ Shayo ♪
-♪ I dey Port Harcourt
when dem kill Soboma ♪
♪ I dey try to buy motor
one Toyota Corolla ♪
♪ My feelings been dey swing
like jangolova ♪
♪ Feelings been dey swing
♪ Now you crash your Ferrari
for Lekki, Burna ♪
♪ Na small thing remain,
it could have been all over ♪
♪ My feelings still dey swing
like jangolova ♪
♪ Feelings still dey swing
like... ♪
♪ Ti n ba ni ke juru e juru ♪
♪ Omo why to'o ki nfe ni suru? ♪
♪ Why you say I did nothing
for you ♪
♪ When I for do anything you
want me to do ♪
♪ Ti n ba ni ke juru e juru ♪
-♪ E juru ♪
-♪ Omo why to'o ki nfe ni suru ♪
-♪ Ni suru ♪
-♪ Why you say I did nothing
for you ♪
♪ When I for do anything
you want me to do ♪
♪ Maybe another time,
maybe another life ♪
♪ You will be my wife
and we'll get it right ♪
♪ E don cast, last last ♪
♪ Na everybody go
chop breakfast ♪
♪ Have to say bye bye o ♪
♪ Bye bye o
to the love of my life ♪
♪ My eye o don cry o ♪
♪ I need igbo and shayo ♪
-♪ Shayo ♪
-♪ I need igbo and shayo ♪
-♪ My shayo ♪
-♪ My Shayo ♪
-♪ Shayo ♪
♪♪
[ Sings in native language ]
♪ Shayo ♪
♪♪
-♪ I need igbo and shayo ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]